Clinton Jones here and for this tutorial
what we're going to be doing is learning
how to add tracer rounds to our war
films so the first thing you want to do
is take our footage and drag it into
this area here to make a new composition
so let's take a look at our footage here
we have our actor camera pans around and
as he's running up tracer rounds are
gonna be coming over this very
protective wall of shrubbery here so
they'll be flying overhead will add some
camera shade color correction and talk
about the various ways to do this effect
you know there's a lot of ways to do it
but I'll be I'll be showing you how to
do one and just briefly describing the
other ways so let's get started first
thing you want to do is come up here and
make a new solid set it to a color
similar to this what I did is I just
brought this slider down to the yellow
you know I had it here and I just slid
it over towards the white so once you
got that you can either make a mask you
know and make kind of like a tracer
shape or what I did was I just brought
these down like this and then just
brought this side in to form like a
tracer shape what we'll do is we will
select our solid and we will go you know
we'll click this button here and select
the 3d box here so we'll make this layer
3d now what we'll do is we're gonna
animate it you know from here flying
overhead so let's rotate it in the right
direction we can use this tool up here
the rotation tool and rotate on the Y
and then some on the Z just like that
maybe a little more on the Y so this is
actually in 3d being stretched out so we
will hit P to bring up the position for
this layer and let's move it back on the
X
just bring it back here bring it down
some and make a keyframe go forward
maybe three frames let's go let's go
four frames if you hit the page down
button then you can just skim through
the frames here just very handy I use it
all the time
and let's bring that flying overhead
like this and you see how it's kind of
off here let's rotate it back just to
match up with this line here on the
z-axis so when this thing's flying
across you know it's going in the right
direction it's not traveling you know
all lopsided and whatnot so let's make
this visible at this point in time so
select the layer hit alt hold alt and
hit left bracket and that will start it
here let's go for frames you know to
where it ends and then just do the same
thing home all and just do the close
bracket so you know this doesn't look
too great it looks pretty pretty
terrible let's spice this up a bit let's
go to let's do a Gaussian blur
throw it on there and let's bump that up
pretty high let's do like 500
maybe like 600 we'll do 600 now with
this you know you can you know this is
one of the other ways of doing this you
can do a motion blur and let's see no
wrong one
it's called directional blur here so we
use the directional blur and we'll get
the angle right you know we'll just buy
it and we'll bring this up to like 600
see but that way like this edge here is
too sharp so we can do a Gaussian blur
as well on top of that maybe like 300 so
it kind of makes it just like a long
streak but you know not you know not too
blurry on the as as for the X&Y but for
the Z needs to be pretty blurry because
it's going really fast now you can
toggle motion blur on and off but it
might be too long you know or too faint
what we'll do is we will let's fix this
problem here looks like it's going
through him you don't want that so you
know what you can do is take the tracer
footage hit ctrl D and we'll just make a
mask around him you know it doesn't have
to be really good and then hit em and
let's animate this once again I'm using
the page down button to pass through
these frames here bring this mask up to
the top title it mask tracer footage so
let's let's select our mask we'll hit f4
feather and click this button here so we
can actually see what we're doing and
let's feather this and let's preview it
nice now it looks really you know it
doesn't look it looks okay let's let's
make the color better let's make it look
more realistic so let's duplicate it
well before we duplicate it you know hit
the toggle switches button and let's set
it to add that way you see it just got
you know it's a little more there's a
glow in the middle here and let's
duplicate it by holding ctrl D there you
see it's really you know there's a big
glow to it so let's check this out
very cool now as a little big over here
what we can do is just bring the scaling
down hit s and just one little on the Y
we can scale it down some undo that make
sure you're not linked so you can just
get the Y set it's like point to 0.5 or
you can even Adam you can keyframe it if
you want so when it gets to about you
know here it's a back tour it was one
point five so it looks like it's kind of
getting bigger bigger as it you know
comes over here so as it gets closer to
the camera so now what we'll do is we
will duplicate this a couple times you
know just make it you know come from
like random spots maybe one over here
now when you move it you see it's gonna
be like traveling in this direction but
just forward so you need to rotate that
on the z
all right so as we scrub by let's make
this mask animate this mask some more so
we'll do it we'll just remove it you
know doesn't have to be doesn't have to
be perfect as long as this is blocked so
that's good so lets you know duplicate
it what I'm just going to pause it and
duplicate it maybe like five or six more
times and what I did was just have them
fly past you know you saw those these
ones just change the direction you know
make them fly right by the camera
because they're 3d so you can make them
do that
you got those there's one probably hit
the cameraman there and then you have
like three coming over here so just very
you know the direction vary the speed
now for these you really don't have to
motion track them just because they're
going so fast now I mean if you wanted
to you could but uh another way of doing
these are you know you can go into
Photoshop and you can just draw a
straight line you know with a soft brush
or something and you can save the
pictures out and just put them away in a
folder so when you want these tracer
rounds you can just import those
pictures make up 3d and go instead of
having to like make a new layer I mean
it doesn't take that much to make a new
layer and a new solid but kind of like
just have like some stock footage at
hand of some tracer rounds so you know
we have these flying over and right here
we might want to do a little camera
shake so what you could do is let's see
let's make our footage 3d and then let's
hit P for position and let's type in
slider control and let's grab that
and put it on the footage now we will
pee once again brandt position will all
click this and for that we'll type in
wiggle parenthesis and we'll type like 8
comma and we'll pick whip this to the
slider here and then we'll close paren
see click off and what you can do is you
know
well that's let's actually go to where
we want maybe right about here so hit
the slider go forward a couple frames
right about here is when we will boost
it up oh we have this mascara we'll get
rid of that in a second
so yeah we boosted it up let's go
forward some more frames just to win
these rounds stop going over and we'll
go to the footage let's hit you and that
brings up all of our key frames let's
just make another keyframe and then go 1
2 3 4 5 6 7
I guess it's 8 set it to 0 so this way
instead of using the wiggler you can use
it like this
and you can control it you know a lot
better you have a lot more precision
with this let's set these to like 30
just because that's a lot of camera
shake 30 let's get a motion tile throw
that on the footage output with 120 up
with height 120 let's do mirror edges
and that will get rid of our problems
here that'll get rid of this black and
we will turn on motion blur for this
layer let's see well oh yeah we have to
fix our mask let's just end our mask
here
let's see what this looks like it looks
nice
it's pretty awesome so let's uh let's
color quick this really quick we'll go a
layer new adjustment layer
let's do color balance throw that guy on
there and this is one of my favorite
color correction techniques I'll set the
blue balance shadow blue to like 30
let's set our mid tone green to 15 and
our high light blue will make it
negative 50 and that's gonna make it
yellow and check preserve preserve
luminosity and it looks really cool
let's throw a tint in here bring it yeah
bring it down here set it to like 50
looks pretty awesome and let's do let's
make another adjustment layer and we'll
go levels let's throw that on there
we'll bring this slider up to darken it
and then we'll select the ellipse tool
and double click it and it'll do it for
you set it to subtract and let's feather
this out once again click this to get
rid of this and you know feather that
out to about there hit T to bring up the
opacity set it's like 80 and now once
you add you know some sound effects you
can really sell this effect it might get
a little too dark in here you can just
vary the opacity animated if you want
but yeah let's add some sound effects
and see what it looks like
thanks for watching this tutorial